The October 2nd Manchester synagogue
attack is ultimately a reflection of
Islam's three most dangerous and hostile
doctrines. To understand this, we must
trace the logic of all such seemingly
senseless terror attacks. You know,
Muslims ramming their vehicles into
andor stabbing random people in Europe.
And happily, the radicals epitomized by
the Islamic State have forthrightly
explained it. The fact is less than 2
months before Mr. Jihad the Syrian, yes
that's reportedly his real name, crashed
his car near the Heaton Park Hebrew
congregation before emerging and
stabbing two Jews to death. The Islamic
State had called on Muslims in Europe to
engage in precisely such attacks. In
August, the Islamic State published an
editorial in its Arabic language
newsletter, Al Nebat, The News. After
praising the slaughter and beheadings of
Christian infidels at the hands of
Muslims throughout Africa, especially in
Mosamb beek and the Democratic Republic
of Congo, it called on Muslims to engage
in the same exact behavior in Europe. In
the words of the editorial, my
translation, ISIS wrote, quote, "May
Allah illumine your paths and preserve
your jihad and assist you in carrying
and delivering it to the shores of
Europe that it might invade them that
the jihad might invade them and disperse
their security and turn their streets
and capitals into another Iti and
another Cabo Delgado. These are
devastated provinces in the Congo and in
Mosmbique that were devastated by
Muslims. And earlier in the editorial,
ISIS was boasting about that for a
Muslim heart still burned for revenge
against the Christians of Europe. And
the call is still open for the champions
of Islam to repeat the same acts upon
them to invade their homeland and bring
down the judgments of Allah upon them as
their brothers are doing in Africa. The
reason the Islamic State says that the
call is still open to slaughter infidels
is because it made an even more explicit
call with detailed instructions, no
less, on how to murder Western infidels
earlier in 2024. On January 3, on
January 3 of that year, after claiming
credit for a terror attack that killed a
100 people in Kermon, Iran, the jihadist
group issued an audio recording titled,
"And kill them wherever you find them,"
which is a verbatim quote of Quran 95.
After urging Muslims not to attack
Israel, as that would only empower the
PA and Hamas, which are not, according
to the Islamic State, true Muslims, it
called on its followers, the so-called
lions of Islam, to quote, listen
carefully, chase your praise, whether
Jewish, Christian, or their allies, on
the streets and roads of America,
Europe, and the world. Break into their
homes, kill them, and steal their peace
of mind by any means you can lay hands
on. understand that you are the arm of
the Islamic State hitting in the Kufar
meaning the infidels homelands and you
are avenging the Muslims in Palestine,
Iraq, Syria and other Muslim nations.
Solidify your plans and diversify the
attacks. Detonate explosives, burn them
with grenades and fiery agents. Shoot
them with bullets. Cut their throats
with sharp knives and run them over with
vehicles. Come at them from every door.
Kill them by the worst of means. Turn
their gatherings and celebrations into
bloody massacres. Do not distinguish
between a civilian career infidel and a
military one. For they are all infidels.
Intentionally seek easy targets before
hard ones, civilian targets before
military ones, religious targets like
synagogues and churches before others.
For this will satisfy the soul and will
demonstrate the characteristics of the
battle as our battle with them is a
religious one and we will kill them
wherever we come upon them in response
to Allah Almighty's command. Again, this
is a reference to Quran 95, also known
as the sword verse, which calls on
Muslims to quote, "Kill the polytheists
wherever you find them, capture them,
besiege them, and lie and wait for them
in every corner. But if they repent,
perform prayers, and pay arms, meaning
if they embrace Islam, then set them
free. Indeed, for Allah is all
forgiving, most merciful." Now, to
justify its calls to slaughter innocent
non-Muslims in ways that everyone in
Europe should be familiar with by now,
including driving vehicles over, blowing
up, and stabbing them to death, little
children included, the Islamic State
spent much time delineating the three
Muslim doctrines I earlier alluded to,
which most support this frenzied blood
lust. Because all non-Muslims would do
well to familiarize themselves with
these three Islamic teachings, for the
remainder of this video, I will break
them down in the context of the Islamic
State's ongoing messaging. Let us begin
with the terror group's most recent
editorial from August 2025.
Very early on, it quotes Quran 9:29,
which reads as follows. quote, "Fight
those who do not believe in Allah in the
last day, nor comply with what Allah and
his messenger have forbidden, nor
embrace the religion of truth from among
the people of the book until they pay
the Jiza with willing submission and in
humility." Now, the mainstream Muslim
understanding of this verse has always
been that Muslims must fight the people
of the book, a reference primarily to
Christians and Jews until they either
convert to Islam, pay Jiza, tribute, and
embrace secondass status, or die.
Incidentally, the fashionable claim
nowadays that this verse is only calling
on Muslims to fight back whenever
Christians and Jews initiate aggression
is a big fat lie. After quoting Quran
9:29, which I just read, the ISIS
editorial continues by reminding the
Christians of Africa that quote, "If
they want to emerge from a state of
death and displacement, they must know
that Islam grants them the freedom
between three choices. One, accept Islam
and they will become our brothers, equal
in rights and duties. Two, pay the Jiza
in humiliation and submission and their
blood will be spared. Three, if they
refuse both, then death, which is what
they have suffered for years. Calls for
jihad and Jiza should by now be
familiar, including to those very few in
the West who are moderately informed,
which I'm sure includes you, dear
viewer. But ISIS also invoked the
overarching doctrine of alwa,
loyalty and enmity. Now let it be known
that this virtually unknown doctrine in
the west is the root source of all
Islamic hostility. Its first part al
commands all Muslims to be loyal and
helpful to one another. Its second and
much more problematic part al commands
Muslims to disavow and even hate all
non-Muslims. It is in fact what fuels
jihad warfare and jiza mistreatment of
conquered infidels. Although there are
many Quran verses that support this
doctrine. Quran 64 is its lynchpin. In
it, Allah informs Muslims that quote,
"You have an excellent example in
Abraham, Ibraim and those with him when
they said to their people, we totally
disassociate ourselves from you and what
you worship besides Allah, we reject
you. Enmity and hatred has arisen
between us and will last forever until
you believe in Allah alone." So, as you
can see, the hate is intrinsic. It's so
final and so total that even if a
non-Muslim is genuinely good and kind to
a Muslim, the Muslim must still hate him
or her. Yes, indeed. While Islam allows
Muslim men to marry women of the book
Christians and Jews, he must nonetheless
hate them and show them he hates them.
Don't believe me? Behold. Over 12 years
ago, I translated a video of Egyptian
cleric Sheikh Yaser Alami responding to
any objections that Islam requires
Muslim men to hate their Christian or
Jewish wives. Please watch it to the
very end and pay careful attention to
his words.
foreign.
for
You are evil. Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
foreign.
Okay. And if you want more proof,
consider the simple, straightforward and
highly authoritative words of Tya, whose
great influence down the centuries has
earned him the singular honorific
al-Islam among Muslims. He wrote, quote,
"The believers, Muslims are loyal to
Allah, and so they are naturally one
another's allies. The infidels are the
enemies of Allah and thus the enemies of
the believers. Allah prohibited
befriending infidels. The believer needs
to reflect on the difference between
these two ways. He needs to know that he
is obligated to befriend a believer even
if he is oppressive and violent towards
you. While he must be hostile to the
infidel, even if he is liberal and kind
to you. Allah Almighty sent prophets and
revealed scripture so that all religion
would be Allah's alone. That there would
be love for his allies, hatred for his
enemies, honor for his allies, contempt
for his enemies, rewards for his allies,
punishments for his enemies. In short, a
Muslim hatred for non-Muslims is an
expression of faith. It is a direct
commandment from Allah with the weight
of heaven and hell attached to it and
thus non-negotiable. All right. Now,
let's see how this doctrine complements
and even actuates its two more popular
counterparts, jihad and jiza. One, hate
for the infidel, that is constant
spiritual or metaphysical hostility
against all non-Muslims, naturally
manifests itself as two, jihad, that is
physical hostility against and attempts
to subjugate the non-Muslim whenever and
wherever possible. and successful jihads
beget three, Jiza, the inhuman
institution that all non-Muslims who
refuse to forfeit the religious freedom
by converting to the Muslim victor's
creed must live under in an Islamic
state. Put differently, a jihad, war on
non-Muslims for no lesser reason than
that they are non-Muslims, is the
physical manifestation of the hate
Muslims should feel for all non-Muslims.
Again, for no lesser reason than that
they are non-Muslims. Incidentally, not
only is it natural to attack and seek to
subjugate those whom one is bred on
hating, but the doctrine of jihad,
including to spread and enforce Sharia
around the world, is let no one deceive
you part and parcel of Islam. Thus,
before it was utterly subverted in the
name of political correctness,
diversity, and all that, when it was
still an authoritative source, the
Encyclopedia of Islam stated the
following under its jihad entry written
by the Lebanese jurist Emil Tayion, who
died in 1977. He wrote, quote, "The
spread of Islam by arms is a religious
duty upon Muslims in general. Jihad must
continue to be done until the whole
world is under the rule of Islam. Islam
must completely be made over before the
doctrine of jihad can be eliminated. But
as infidels are to be hated per se and
not merely in the context of jihad, the
hostility continues even after the
cessation of successful holy wars.
Unlike other conquerors that generally
permit the conquered to go on unmolested
so long as they do not challenge the new
order, some even try to appease and win
over their new subjects. Whenever and
wherever Islam conquers, that old
metaphysical hostility, the hate which
fueled the original jihad, remains to
mistreat its subject infidels. Thus, not
only must the Christians and Jews pay
extortion money, Jiza, and accept
secondass citizen status, according to
the jeritical text, they must also be
reminded and made to feel inferior,
including as a way to inspire them to
convert to the true faith. Some Islamic
jeritical texts go so far as to mandate
humiliating rituals at the time of Jiza
payment. The presiding Muslim official
could slap, choke, and or pull the beard
of the paying Christian or Jew, who
might also be made to approach the
official on all fours like an animal.
Either way, Islam wins. If the infidel
continues in his faith, Islamic society
continues to extort and prey on him. If
the non-Muslim eventually surrenders to
Islam, the ummah gains a new recruit
with death as a penalty should he later
entertain second thoughts and try to
apostatize. Such has been the true
history and growth of the Islamic world.
All of which is built at top the blood
and land of non-Muslims. Indeed, all
that we've discussed is a perfect
description of historic Islam. It
preached undying hatred for infidels,
invaded and conquered their lands, and
placed those who refused to convert in a
state of degradation and bondage. See
this book, Sword and Scimitar, 14
centuries of war between Islam and the
West, if you want countless examples
from the 7th century to the modern era.
ignore and returning to the most recent
expression of Islamic hate in jihad, the
Manchester synagogue attack, to say
nothing of the ongoing genocide of
Christians throughout Africa. Is any of
this a limited to the past? It is, as we
see on a daily basis, all very alive and
well in the present.
[Music]